SPEAKER: Hi, everyone.
Thanks for joining us today
to see a quick demo of Migrate
for Anthos.
This demo shows how a
multi-tier application running
on VM or on prem can be migrated
and run on GKE containers.
It also shows how to update an
image using the Create a Doctor
file and how to deploy
the updated image
as part of day two operations.
So just a little bit
of an orientation.
The demo covers an application
server and a database server
running on VM or on prem.
We're going to migrate
them to a GKE cluster
where the relevant
services, like load
balancer and the
database application,
were moved as well.
We'll extract the image,
apply it to the cluster,
and then we'll go through an
image update using Cloud Build
and apply that update using
rolling upgrade to the cluster.
This is the VMware
deployment we have on prem.
As you can see, the application
server and the database server
are running two different
operating systems, one SUSE
Linux and the other CentOS.
And for the purpose
of this demo,
we already migrated the Suite
CRM database as a StatefulSet
and will now migrate the SUSE
web and application server.
First, let's look at the
application running on prem.
This is an open source
CRM application.
It's using a LAMP stack.
You can see here the
application running.
Now let's switch over to
the Kubernetes cluster side.
And here you can see suitecrm-db
container already running
as a stateful set.
We also have the load balancer
setup for the application.
And it will serve it
once the application
is executed on the cluster.
Let's go and install the
Migrate for Anthos software
on that cluster.
For that, we will use the
migctl setup install command.
The migctl is available
on Cloud Shell.
And the setup install command
will connect to the cluster
and apply the different
solution components.
You can then run
migctl doctor to see
that installation is complete.
And in that case, it will
return a check on deployment.
If there are any issues, it
will be shown here instead
of the check on deployment.
Next, we will
configure the source
from virtual machines that
are going to be migrated.
And you configure
multiple sources.
In this demo, we will define
the VMware on prem as a source.
So we'll configure the
manager address for Migrate
for Compute Engine and the
cloud extension to which we
want to connect to so that we
can use migrate for Compute
Engine as a
transport and you can
see the source as configured.
Next, we'll create
a migration plan.
For this, we'll identify the
VM we would like to migrate.
This is the VM we
saw on the VM side.
And since it is a
stateless application,
we will specify an image
for the intent flag
and then create the
migration command
to ask only for
image extraction.
The migration plan is
written into a YAML file that
can be reviewed and customized.
In the YAML file, you'll
see the definitions
for the different artifacts
that are going to be generated,
as well as default filters
for exclusions of directories
and files that are not going
to be included in the image as
well as the target image
names for deploying into GCR
once these are built.
Next, we're going to
generate the artifacts.
Basically, feeding
this migration plan
into the Migrate for
Anthos will execute
the migration and the breakdown
of these different artifacts.
For this, we will
use the makectl
generate artifacts command.
First, the migration
plan is validated.
And then it's applied
to the cluster.
The migration is
applied as a CRD
so you can also use
the CRD as an API
to automate this migration.
Then you'll use the
makectl migration status
to monitor the status and
progress of this migration
throughout its
different activities.
What you'll see now is that
since we're communicating
with the on prem
VMware system, the VMs
that are still running on prem
will be picked into a snapshot.
And from that we will
start extracting the image.
Here we can see that the
image extraction applied
into GCR with the image
name that we configured
into the migration plan.
So we skipped the entire
upload process to GCR.
In addition, in a
bucket in GCS, you
will find the set of created
artifacts as doctor file
and deployment
artifacts that are
usable for further
deployment and day
two operations when you'd like
to update this image later.
To download the
artifacts, you can
use the migctl migration
get artifacts command
with the migration name.
And you can see the deployment
spec that was automatically
created or the image that
was automatically built.
And this deployment
spec can be applied
to this or any other
cluster where you would
like to run these workloads.
So let's go ahead and
apply the deployment
so that we can see the
application running.
Now that the
deployment is applied,
it is inserted into the
environment we precreated.
Just as a reminder, we have
a load balancer set up.
And we also have an
autoscaler configured.
So when this deployment
goes into place,
the autoscaler kicks
in automatically
and sets up a minimum and
maximum pods and the monitoring
on the CPU metrics according
to those conditions.
So you can immediately see some
of the Kubernetes capabilities
in action.
Now let's connect to
the load balancer.
And you can see the
application running.
We'll just connect to this
internal load balancer
and you can see the
application now running in GKE.
Now that the
application is running,
we're switching to talk
about day two operations.
Let's say that we
have a package that
is a user mode
package in the image
and we would like to update it.
In this case, we will
put the user mode package
for update in the doctor file
that we downloaded as part
of the generate artifacts.
This is, for example,
an Open SSH package.
Then this doctor file can
be fed into Cloud Build
with a single G Cloud command.
And we get a new
built image that
includes the updated package.
We're using here an
update for SUSE Linux.
So we're using the
package manager in Zipper
to update the image.
We want you to see
the image built.
We've accelerated this process.
It usually takes 12 to
13 minutes to complete,
but we sped this up a bit
for the sake of this demo.
Now that the image
is updated and built,
if we go to the repository,
we can see the updated image
version.
And we can go and
perform a rolling update
on the actual deployment.
Remember that we have now a
deployment with three pods
running the web
front end, so we're
going to apply a live update.
In this live update, you
will see the new version
being provisioned alongside
the old version and then
the old version
being decommissioned.
During this process, the
application is staying up.
And you can see that here.
While this process is
going on, the application
is still accessible.
And in a few seconds, the update
process will be completed.
And now we can see the updated
image version has been applied.
And we did not have to
touch any of these instances
individually.
That concludes our demo of
Migrate for Anthos today.
Thank you so much for
taking the time to watch it.
And we look forward to more
demo videos in the future.